thank you very much for joining us we
begin this NewsHour in Gaza where for a
second day Israel has carried out air
strikes one person has been killed in
the latest attack which the Israeli Army
says targeted the Palestinian Islamic
Jihad group it's a day after at least 15
people were killed by Israeli strikes on
the Strip three of them were commanders
from Islamic jihad's military Wing let's
go live to Al jazeera's yumna al-said
who's in Gaza City forest United had
been quiet for most of the morning but
things picking up in the last hours so
tell us about what's been happening
[Music]
yes Foley so as you mentioned it has
been quite
cautious called
about half an hour ago when Israeli
airstrikes started taking place in
different areas in the Gaza Strip uh the
latest strike was in the northern part
of the Gaza Strip mostly on military
camps belonging to putz brigades that's
the military wing of Islamic Jihad also
agriculture lands and the lands that are
adjacent to the Israeli Gaza border have
all been targeted in these latest
airstrikes uh also just a while ago
before these or prior to these
airstrikes there was an airstrike in the
southern part of the Gaza Strip in Han
Eunice and another in Rapa where two
people uh were targeted one was
announced or pronounced to uh to to be
killed and the other in a critical
condition they were taken to hospital in
Rafa in the southern Gaza Strip other
than that the general mood in Gaza stays
very on very high alert there's a very
high sense of worry and tension among
the residents everything else is closed
in Gaza schools educational facilities
have shut down and other public and
private facilities while people have
limited their uh going out of their
homes to just purchasing their
Necessities looking at the latest
pictures that we are getting out of Gaza
of the aftermath of this Israeli
airstrike yumna has there been a
response from the Palestinian factions
from Islamic Jihad
no response at all has been done by any
of the Palestinian factions here fully
and that's why I was saying the the the
sense or the general mood is very high
alert even no uh statements have been
made further statements other than the
ones that have been made on Tuesday
saying that there is going to be a
unified uh response by all the policy
infections but no response until this
moment has been done by any of the
Palestinian factions now no launching of
rockets nothing at all okay you know
we'll keep a close eye on the situation
there in Gaza with you you know outside
right there in Gaza City now across the
Gaza border people in southern Israel
are also on high alert villain Marx has
more from Ashkelon
the authorities are telling people to
expect the possibility of Rocket fire
we're a few miles north of Gaza here and
all but essential traffic is being
blocked by checkpoints on the major
roads a lot of the local schools have
been closed for today so that's
thousands of kids at home people
yesterday dozens of families were told
by local authorities moving away from
the communities that are close to Gaza
and indeed many that are remaining being
told to stay very close to shelters
Israeli media reporting that prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu will later
today reassess the situation for these
communities in the south of Israel we
should expect therefore around five or
six pm local time to hear whether they
will lift those measures but he has said
to people in a press conference last
night do pay attention to what local
authorities are instructing he was
speaking alongside his defense minister
joav golant saying that the Israeli Army
is prepared for attacks from any and all
directions but right here overnight you
know we've not seen a huge amount of
military activity we spotted one tank at
a local gas station we've heard a couple
of drones in the sky people last night
and today in Ashland just up the road
outside enjoying restaurants and cafes
in the Town Center
and Israeli forces have killed two
Palestinians as part of an overnight
operation in kabatier south of Janine in
the occupied West Bank the Islamic Jihad
group says they were part of its
paramilitary group a 17 year old
Palestinian is in hospital after being
shot in the chest by Israeli forces
and the Israeli military says it's
arrested 19 Palestinians in overnight
raids elsewhere in the occupied West
Bank targets included the town of Bates
Umar near Hebron and the tucom refugee
camp in the north of the territory near
Ramallah three Palestinians were wounded
in an attack by Israeli settlers Sarah
has more from Ramallah in the occupied
West Bank
usually when these raids take place by
the Israeli forces they're targeted they
are going fast they go in the morning
when most people are asleep they go in
they kill those that they are on their
Wanted list and they're out very quickly
this time they went in they shot two
people because the Israeli forces say
that these Palestinians were shooting
back at them now these raids that are
happening across the West Bank are
happening on a daily basis this latest
one was near Refugee the refugee camp
called Janine that's where uh uh more
than 30 Palestinians have been killed
since the beginning of the year you also
have nablis for example where also more
than 30 Palestinians were killed those
two areas are considered hot spots in
the West Bank especially this year in
terms of armed resistance a lot of
Palestinians that even though we spoke
to just a few days ago in one of the
refugee camps say they've reached a
point where negotiations political
negotiations with Israel is not working
that this new government that came into
Power this year is increasing
authoritarian it's going into these
refugee camps and killing Palestinians
every single day you have 128
Palestinians killed in just five months
across all these occupied territories
and we are seeing a lot more armed
resistance from the Palestinians a lot
of them are young men that say that they
don't have prospects they're fed up they
said they don't see a future for the
Palestinians as long as this Israeli
government especially this current new
right-wing government is increasingly
expanding uh its territories it's
increasingly expanding its illegal
Jewish settlements well as we heard from
yumna earlier the Israeli military has
said it's targeting rocket launch sites
held by the Palestinian Islamic Jihad
movement in Gaza Islamic Jihad is a
smaller of the two main Palestinian
groups in Gaza much smaller than the
governing Hamas the exact size of its
membership is unknown estimates range
from a thousand to several thousand
Fighters analysts say despite its size
it's very active in confrontations with
Israel the group's aim is the
establishment of a Palestinian state but
for now it refuses to take part in
elections Israel accuses Islamic Jihad
of being a proxy for Iran it gets funds
and weapons from Tehran Western Nations
listed as a terrorist organization well
joining us now on the NewsHour is Khalid
Abu hate who's the media spokesman for
Islamic Jihad is joining us from Beirut
thank you very much Mr Abu hate for
speaking to us on Al Jazeera so as
you've heard more Israeli Rays on Gaza
today targeting Islamic Jihad targets
three senior leaders of movement were
killed on Tuesday what is your reaction
first to these racist developments and
how will Islamic Jihad respond
uh thank you for being uh at your media
now we're looking at the Israeli enemy
don't hesitate to launch any battle to
Target any civilians our leaders have
been killed between their families wives
children he targeted civilian buildings
the the enemy has started this point now
we looked at he started this battle but
he cannot
State one to end and to what extent this
battle will go all choices are open and
we are our response will not be delayed
for long that's for sure how to respond
to respond this is this is I'll assure
that our response is coming you've said
this and we've heard this yesterday also
that your response is coming Islamic
Jihad has promised a tough response
after the killing of its senior members
and yet we haven't seen anything until
now is it because that your perhaps
concerned that Israel wants to elicit a
response from you precisely because it
wants to draw you into a conflict
tried to drag us to a battle and he uh
put the situation which is suitable for
for his forces we in Islamic Jihad will
respond to that crime but we will uh we
will respond in the way that we assure
that all the goals and objectives of
this Association and of this attack will
be failed we will defeat the objective
of this
yeah but but as you say if there is a
response uh Mr Abu Haiti if there is a
response from Islamic Jihad Israel will
no doubt Target uh the Palestinian
people of Gaza again is that something
that your movement is prepared to to uh
accept today I mean there could be
another war in Gaza where people are
suffering and Palestinian people suffer
our our president people suffer but who
who is the cause of this suffering uh is
it Islamic Jihad that allows that
launches this battle
um uh the the security forces the of
Israel have been killed and targeted our
senior leaders have been has uh killed
in his uh prison uh they didn't release
it it make all the situation to go into
a conflict yet
didn't make any response and
despite of this the
Israeli government took the uh took the
uh to make this conflict
sorry so we we are looking that this uh
is happening because because uh of the
crack the Cowardly assassination is
related to the political goals related
to the this agreements within
netanyahu's government Coalition we all
have heard LinkedIn and his conditions
on the government of Netanyahu this is
not related to what Islamic Jihad has
done or not done this is related to the
disagreement this is related to the
Netanyahu okay and the cases he strived
in uh but we care a lot but if we don't
respond this means that this equation
this unit this equalizing government
will will come back and will go back to
the assassination we still remember how
the Israel's forces have translated a
lot of gazians a lot of our people
between after after the the coming out
of Gaza Strip in 2005. okay let me just
pick up on what you said Mr Applegate
this is very this is really important
you say that Israel's actions right now
are linked to internal Israeli politics
and that Israel the Netanyahu government
wants to drag Islamic Jihad and the
Palestinian factions into a conflict if
that's the case as you say and Islamic
Jihad is preparing a response as you say
aren't you then falling into netanyahu's
trap
you've talked about how Israel this is
all related to internal Israeli politics
if that's the case then you say that
Islamic Jihad needs to respond to these
latest actions are you not then falling
into the Israeli government's trap
no no no no no but what if we haven't
respond failure to respond to the
assassination means opening the way for
the extremist government to return to
the polishing position of assassination
again to encourage the villages and the
the areas in the mixed bank and the
cities of the West Bank and to give the
extremity groups in the entity the
opportunity to monopolize the Al-Aqsa
mosque we don't have any other choice
but to respond if we don't respond the
the situation will be worse we have to
respond thank you so much for taking the
time to speak to us Khalid Abu hates
media spokesman for the Islamic Jihad
movement for having me joining us there
from Beirut thank you for your time